Our next grand guest has a play to win attitude
that makes her all the goals!
At the age of 59, Deborah Houston is a mother
and grandmother to six and a great grandmother to three
but what makes her stand out even more?
well she just made history as the oldest soapbox derby racer
in the country.
That's right, here she is, it's Deborah!
(audience cheering, clapping)
Hi Drew.
Hi Deborah.
I'm so excited to meet you.
And I'm excited to meet you too.
How did you end up getting into soapbox racing?
Well, you know, Indianapolis is known for the racing
and a friend of mine had approached me
about taking my grandchildren to do the soapbox racing.
And so I thought it would be a good thing
for them to get them off the computers,
it'll teach them responsibility
and give them something to do during the pandemic.
So I took them to practice
and they met their coach, Mr. Larry
and Mr. Larry kept approaching me about racing.
He said, "You the perfect size,
you're gonna fit in that car,"
he said, "Come on and do it."
And I kept thinking about it, thinking about it
and I finally said, "Okay, I'll try it."
I love it, because I learned
that the oldest soapbox racer in your team is 14,
right?
Right.
I just love this, this is so cool.
Tiny but mighty.
Now what was going through your head
the first time you were like...
Well, at first I was a little nervous
and I was hyperventilating because I wasn't so nervous
and I went down the hill and when I went down the hill,
I said, "Oh, I can do this, I can do this,"
and I started practicing and kept going down the hill
and it turned out to be fun.
At the same time I was going through chemo
so I said, "Well, rather than sit up
and worry about chemo, I could be practicing and having fun
and just doing this with my grandchildren,"
and I really enjoyed it.
(audience clapping)
And is it true that you're doing fantastically well now?
Yes, I am cancer free.
Whoo!
(audience cheering)
Yes!
(Drew exhales deeply)
And I asked that right away when I found out
and it's just so important and your story, your attitude,
the fact that you wanna get your kids out off the technology
and out into the world during the pandemic,
the fact that you had cancer and were going through this,
but chose to spend your time doing and focusing on this,
you are the example.
Thank you, Drew, thank You.
Thank you.
It's true.
I'm happy.
You are, what's next for you?
What else are we going to learn from you?
Well, I'm gonna go race this 2021
and this year I'm gonna win.
So (indistinct) is to race and to win in 2021.
Well, you are the biggest winner
and we wanna be cheering you on
and I have a little something for you.
Oh, really?
For me?
Yeah, this is a little-
Oh, it's got my name on!
Oh yeah, it does.
I hope you don't mind,
I put a little logo of our show on there, here you go.
Oh my goodness, that's a racing suit.
And it's just perfectly or size
and I will say it's sturdy, but it's also really soft.
Oh my goodness, thank you.
Thank you, Drew.
It is such a pleasure, but that's not all, check this out.
So we know you live in Indianapolis.
So we reached out to the Indy 500.
When they heard about you,
they wanted to give you a few things as well.
So they wanna have you wave the green flag
for the Indy 500 practice day.
Yeah, that's right.
Goodness!
Oh goodness, Drew, oh my goodness!
How cool is that?
And they also-
It's really cool.
Oh, that just makes me feel so good, thank you.
Well, they also wanna put your soapbox on display
in their fan area on actual race day and host you
and all your grandchildren on practice day and show you off
like a little Deborah museum!
Thank you so much, thank you.
Oh, Deborah, do you mind if we speak to you again
and ask you how that day went and just check in?
Yes, oh, you can.
Please call me, please call me, please, please call me.
I'll cook for you.
Okay, good, I'm so ready.
Deborah, I need more, I wanna like catch up
and see how that day went and thank you to the Indy 500
who gets it, wants to honor Deborah.
We honor you here at this show, we love you
and I can't thank you enough
for being here to be that example.
Thank you, Drew and thank you for having me
and thank you for all of that.
Thank you so much.
Oh, thank you, Deborah.
(upbeat music)